salut romain ça ouais ça va oui tout va
bien pas de problème
bah ouais ouais parce que d'habitude
c'est pour le pour l'intro bah oui mais
là ça va
hockey a changé il ya quelques temps je
vous ai fait une proposition j'étais de
cacao qu aux yeux
d'ailleurs je vous ferai peut-être un
épisode 20 jours pour vous raconter
pourquoi on a eu quelques occasions
vous avez été nombreuses et vous avez
été nombreux à me le réclamer donc j'en
déduis que pourquoi on a des cacaos
point des yeux c'est là je suis sûr que
ça vous est déjà arrivé ça vous arrive
peut-être même tous les matins vous
dormait tranquillement le réveil sonne
kaka dingue dès qu'hakan oeil pour
comprendre d'où viennent les cacas deuil
faut savoir de base que l'oeil à une
sorte de fonction auto nettoyante c'est
pas le seul il ya d'autres organes qu'on
a aussi comme par exemple les oreilles
avec le cérumen les voies respiratoires
avec le mucus et les crottes de nez et
les organes génitaux avec les pertes
blanches et le smig manoir de
l'impliquer bien sûr alors vous allez me
dire pour les autres organes on voit
bien ce qu'il peut y avoir à nettoyer
mais dans les yeux y'a quoi et moi je
vais vous répondre
plein de trucs d'abord vous le savez nos
cellules et se régénère en permanence
celle de nos yeux et de l'intérieur de
nos paupières aussi du coup ça fait
plein de petites saloperies
microscopiques à évacuer mais c'est pas
tout vous savez aussi bien que moi les
yeux c'est à la fois très précieux et
très fragile notamment la cornée et la
conjonctive les membranes transparentes
sont à la surface de l'oeil
du coup pour éviter qu'elle se dessèche
et pour éviter que ça accroche on
sécrète une substance qui s'appelle la
mutine et une sorte de mucus lubrifiants
donc nos yeux sont aussi autour du
griffier quand vous dites comme les
organes génitaux la médecine c'est juste
une des trois couches qui recouvre
l'oeil pour le protéger et qu on appelle
le film lacrymal
en plus de tout ce petit monde bien
évidemment il ya des bactéries qui
essaye de s'incruster
et du coup il ya des enzymes qu'on
appelle les lysozyme qui sont là pour
les éliminer sans parler de tout ce qui
est poussière et autres cochonneries
qu'on peut alors dans l'oeil pendant la
journée tous assez pris en charge par
les larmes qui font aussi partie de
l'équipe de nettoyage et bras s'est dit
lui elle évacue tout ça grâce à la
mutation
la mutation non mais c'est un mouvement
au cours duquel les paupières se ferment
et se retrouve très rapidement assez de
l'ordre de 100 à 150 millisecondes
oui c'est éric veilleux oui oui le
niveau donc dans la journée mais à
toutes ces sécrétions ces petits pots
ces cellules ces poussières
elles sont évacuées sans qu'on s'en
rende compte dans un battement de cils
et l'excédent de larmes
il est évacué par un petit couloir de
service qui s'appelle le canal lacrymo
nasal et qui relie le coin interne de
l'oeil au nez c'est pour ça qu'on
renifler qu'on a le nez qui coule quand
on pleure mais la nuit alors déjà la
nuit on sécrète moins de larmes
toute cette petite soupe qu'on a dans
l'oeil et devient plus grosse entrée
comme une espèce de potages si vous
voulez et puis surtout on fume pas des
yeux
donc ça stagne s'assèche et quand on se
réveille alors en réalité cet amas de
matière il porte un autre nom
ça s'appelle la châssis et alors c'est
là où ça devient savoureux c'est
l'anagramme 2 vous rigolez mais est ce
que vous saviez que lemouchia si ça
vient du latin populaire catch it a lui
même dérivé du latin classique
kkr et qui veut dire des flics et la
boucle est bouclée
donc vous avez compris avoir des cacas
autour des yeux au réveil pas de
problème c'est normal tout va bien c'est
important d'apprendre à les connaître
pour mieux vivre avec
bon après ça reste des d'échec le corps
évacués dont la peine de les manger mon
truc alors oui quand même
évidemment si vos kaka d'oeil ils ont
une couleur bizarre ou s'ils viennent
plus foncée si vous en avez plus que
d'habitude où vous aurez la journée ou
que ça vous gêne pas dans les encours
même à votre médecin voit la dtcc fini
pour aujourd'hui si vous vous posez des
questions de ce genre d'un autre genre
là n'hésitez pas à me les poser sur
facebook ou par mail à l'adresse
question dtc @ gmail point com
on se retrouve très vite pour de
nouvelles vidéos d'ici là mettez vous
bien et surtout portez vous bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]